now that the movies and theaters
birds-of-prey fans can finally dig into
the film's massive ensemble twisted set
pieces and inventive action with so much
going on it can be easy to miss all the
plot developments or know where everyone
stands by the end we're here to help
we're gonna have to work together birds
of prey subtitles how's the film as the
story of Harley Quinn's fantabulous
emancipation and it is hardly starts the
film as an emotional wreck prone to
binge drinking crying jags and blowing
up chemical plants that all changes when
she gains a chance to earn her freedom
from her bad reputation and bonds with
the rest of the birds of prey team by
the end of the film she's got a new
protege in Cassandra Cain a new probably
not legal business and a new reputation
as someone who can get things done but
the grenade explosion death of romance
Ionis doesn't necessarily mean all of
her least trouble is about to go away
she used to roll with the Joker after
all and no matter how far she gets from
that relationship there's someone
somewhere looking to cause her pain for
her past sins Harley is smart enough to
notice and she'll no doubt be looking
over her shoulder for the next great
threat when we first meet Cassandra Cain
she's a low-level pickpocket who wanders
the streets of Gotham trying to avoid
going back to the crappy apartment where
her parents are constantly fighting over
the course of the film she goes on a
massive adventure becomes the focus of a
citywide scavenger hunt and finds a new
big sister figure in the form of Harley
Quinn
Cassandra's got a whole new life ahead
of her as Hartley's protege what does
she do now the possibilities seem
endless considering who she's hanging
out with but one path seems very likely
yes the film version of Cassandra is
very different from the comics but we do
know that comics Cassandra took on the
role of Batgirl for a while it would
take a few years and a little training
but perhaps movie Cassandra could also
pull that off
detective Renee Montoya starts the film
as a rough edge to determine smart
Gotham City cop with a tendency toward
alcoholism and deep resentment toward
her mostly male colleagues for taking
promotions she deserved by the end she's
not exactly a new woman but she does
seem to have renewed purpose the
vigilante life will allow her to do the
kind of good in Gotham that she never
could
with a badge Renae becomes a founding
member of the birds of prey alongside
her new friends Hellena Bertinelli and
Dinah Lance cementing her place as a
crime fighter outside the realm of the
law her old cop connections will no
doubt make her very good at that job but
it's not necessarily the end of Renee's
evolution longtime DC Comics readers
know Renee eventually became the new
incarnation of masked vigilante the
question a transition we could still see
on the big screen someday Black Canary
is something of a mystery when we meet
her she's a lounge singer at black
mask's Club doing whatever she can to
get by but then she displays tremendous
fighting abilities as well as her
supersonic canary cry which lets us all
know that she's got gifts she's been
keeping under wraps what the film
doesn't tell us is how and why canary is
so gifted which means her backstory is
ripe for exploration and future films
with canary now one of Gotham City's
most visible vigilantes there's nowhere
to go but up in upcoming films we could
certainly see her comic book love
interest Green Arrow one day though a
version of the canary arrow dynamic did
just recently play out on the small
screen for eight seasons
Elena Bertinelli seems like the most
straightforward character in the title
team because she seems to have only one
real motivation avenge the deaths of her
family members by killing everyone tied
to it when she finally kills the last
person she believes to be involved in
the massacre Victor Zsasz Elena has to
find something else to live for
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
by the end of the film
Elena may not have shed any of the
leftover awkwardness from her
single-minded pursuits as the Huntress
but she has gained a broader perspective
of the world as Renee Montoya noted
she's fooling herself if she thinks the
symptoms of the problem that killed her
family stopped with the last name on her
list now as a member of the birds of
prey she has a new outlet for making the
world a better place and stopping the
deaths of other families in the process
using her regained inheritance to fund
the whole operation
birds-of-prey sets up romance Ionis AKA
black mask as a true big bag worthy of
herpes fear Roman is a truly terrifying
unhinged mob boss who seems to have
bought and killed his way to the top
to the point that by the end of the film
he basically has an army at his beck and
call plus we know that a lot of what
he's done in the past means very few mob
leaders are fit to challenge him and
those that do find themselves without
faces but by the end of the film
Gotham's most powerful mob boss has been
blown to bits on Founders pure his
right-hand man is also dead and there
suddenly a very prominent power vacuum
and Gotham's underworld so who's going
to rise up and fill that void there are
a lot of candidates who could step up
particularly with the Joker's seemingly
out of the picture perhaps it's time for
the penguin to become the big screen
crime lord we've all been waiting to see
much like the Joker Batman doesn't
appear in birds of prey but his presence
is felt nonetheless hardly references
him as part of her origin story noting
he arrested her after she helped Joker
break out of Arkham Asylum he is often
either the butt of Harley's jokes or
serves as a reminder that Harley still
remembers her encounters with him
he's also brought up in subtler ways for
one thing Harley Quinn's pet hyena is
named Bruce and she's so proud of that
name that she wears it on a chain around
her neck he's named after billionaire
playboy Bruce Wayne named him Bruce
after Thank You Wayne guy so does Harley
know that Bruce Wayne is Batman
then there's the post-credits audio
snippet and which hardly promises to
tell us a secret she gets as far as
saying it Batman before the audio cuts
given her hyenas name could one assume
hardly is sweet on the Batman we may
never know but it's fun to think about
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the DC movie universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bells so you don't miss a single one
[Music]